[Music]
one canteen
[Music]
[Music]
Lucca Nate here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're doing
some exploring and camping and hiking I
have heard rumors of some remote
waterfalls and swimming holes some caves
and maybe even some abandoned mines in
this valley and we're gonna see if we
can't find them and this is Nathan's
first real hike and he's uh he's only
five so we're gonna give it a go and see
how he does here well check it out just
in case we run into any people on the
trail nathan is wearing his ninja mask
that's your ninja mask hahahaha
when one of our neighbors sowed a bunch
of camo masks for all the boys is really
sweet the dabbing ninja
looks like the path is kind of flooded
we need we need to find the way around
oh yeah use all your ninja skills okay
good alright I think we've found the
path again all right let's keep going
you goodnight look at how pretty this
water is
the flowers are blooming these little
waterfalls everywhere it's just gorgeous
here
[Music]
Oh Nathan pick it out the trails flooded
I think you better bushwhack around
[Music]
yeah he's betting it'll rock
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
there's the path let's see if we can
find another way around
[Applause]
there you go
haha this is pretty
keep going but nice and easy
there's the path and you can see it
crosses back over again but we have to
get across this water folks hold on that
treat you good good job buddy
got it all by yourself
oh I didn't like that path next time I'm
boarding the river
oh let's see if daddy can fit through
here
hey Nathan need to check this out look
at that that's a spring all right got a
major landmark gonna do a little
navigation here are you that waterfall
it's rained on and off for three days
and I just barely cleared up this
morning so this river is definitely
swollen we're high up in the mountains
though so it should clear up pretty
quickly and I'm hoping by tomorrow on
our way back we'll be able to afford the
river instead of having to climb over
all those rocks and cliffs to get back
plus it doesn't matter if we get wet on
our way back we don't want to get wet on
our way in
you having fun Nathan good check it out
this pad was brand new when I put it on
my back this morning oh alright
all right come on whoa he was lit in
that was a ninja move our path is kind
of a river here are you ready Nate
Nathan's eaten pocket raisins I want one
oh yeah let's oh yeah yogurt covered
trail snack mom yeah I'll look around
see if we can find a cave I heard that
they're my beasts and caves around here
we're gonna see if we could find them
not sure we will though there's a cave
right over there at the bottom those
rocks
there's no nice and slow
look at that see the water is going into
the rocket it's digging a hole in the
rock
look at that that's absolutely stunning
well this sure is a pretty spot in an
awesome swimming hole but this is not
the waterfall we were looking for so we
got to keep looking and see if we can't
find that
there's another beautiful swimming hole
right there look how deep that is well
we found this swimming hole now I want
to find an abandoned mine apparently
there used to be a manganate iron ore
mine around here it's been all abandoned
and there's some ruins but I have really
sketchy details on where exactly it is
so we're gonna have to get a little wet
I'm afraid I think we're gonna have to
cross the river all right I think we
need to cross the river I'm gonna get a
little wet
nice healthy pink color well there we go
I'm a little damp but I'm still dry
brisk and refreshing that was oh look
some leftover structure from the mining
operation
look there's a sand concrete over there
some footings here look at that wonder
if there's more I check it out here's
more of the mine see yes
so old bricks here these more parts to
that old mine you can see the rock wall
part of a foundation right here probably
it used to be a house here well so far
this is the most we found from the mine
I believe they used to mine manganate
and iron here
the caves are over this way all right
time to get wet again
[Applause]
you back there Nate take out this plant
we're climbing through these are
rhododendron they're native to China and
they've been introduced and spread all
over the country you've been out in the
middle of nowhere there's tons of them
good-looking enough the ollie's
rhododendron bushes when we were in
Scotland they were all over there too
Dave can't go around there
we can't get around that we are killing
ourselves trying to find these cave we
saw the caves across the river and
they're just over this next ridge but
they're at the base of a cliff and of
obviously we don't want to approach it
from the top of the cliff and around the
sides but you just can't do it sheer
rock wall in whitewater so I think I
think we're not going to make it on the
caves maybe on another day when the
water level is lower
whoa well half my body has been bathed
very thoroughly today all right this
one's a good a spot as any to set up
camp whoo let's drop our packs and start
buying some firewood Oh
oh my goodness I've had that pack on for
six hours now I I suddenly feel so light
[Applause]
oh this is so much lighter than my pack
this is good and dry look at this snap
snap snap
oh that snap sounds perfect wait did you
find a stick oh that's a big one
I brought my Japanese he go no commie
knife this is a traditional Japanese
folding knife now that's a marshmallow
stick hold on to that sucker
all right so I got some cotton balls
soaked in Vaseline I put a couple
underneath the tinder right there and
the rest I'm going to put on the end of
this stick here then I'm going to take
my blast match make a little torch here
see easy peasy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you guys haven't seen this already
this is by one man backpacking tent it's
a little over three pounds it's the Alps
mountaineering one-man tent it's about
90 bucks I got it on amazon.com I'll put
a link in the description but if you
guys want to know more about tadd so you
think about buying a tent I did a tent
review video that's pretty helpful I'll
put a link in the description of that as
well let's go get some water Nate
all right so Nate using the live straw I
just take the ends off and drink through
it like a straw all right yeah go for it
you drink right there and I'm gonna load
up your canteen
hey neat would you like me to build you
a bench
there you go the rocks starting to heat
up and you can see it's cracked and
broke it in a few places it'll probably
break in a few more places by time we're
done but that's really typical you just
got to be careful with certain types of
rocks that don't have good straight
cleavage they tend to explode on you
slate and shale tend to be the best ones
so you what do you want for dinner
okay we're humming noodle and I brought
along steak and artisan bread but Nathan
wants to eat cup of noodle and hot
chocolate
that's his jam we're gonna stick to it
oh yeah we getting some sizzle on there
[Music]
if big old campfire stakes on rocks is
kind of your thing check out my campfire
cooking playlist I've got tons of videos
there including one where I made bread
from scratch and cooked it on rocks so
definitely check it out I'll put a link
in the description all right I got a
loaf of sourdough bread we're gonna heat
this up on the rock as well don't need
to cook it just warm it up
there we go
look there's a lot of bears in this area
so we're gonna have to make sure and
clean up our camp really good before we
go to bed and get all these greasy rocks
far away from us if you see a bear what
are you gonna do I'm gonna attack it
with your ear survival for my sweet wife
packed me one of her homemade coconut
mochi bars for dessert
oh well that's better than the steak
sandwich mmm
alright buddy you want to rush
marshmallows look at these see they're
like small planets now that is what I
call a perfect marshmallow look at that
baby whoo that's a good marshmallow but
I feel like I'm cheating on my wife she
loves roasted marshmallows and she
should be here to be enjoying this let
me see your head oh my goodness Mellie
you want to avoid all right well the Sun
is setting it's Nathan's bedtime but I
promise to go in there and watch some
shows with him on the phone and and
we're just gonna relax until we go to
sleep
[Music]
sometime a man wear stretchy pants when
he's alone by the fire he's for fun
good morning you having fun
well it's only 10:00 a.m. and already
it's a much warmer day so me and Nathan
need to make a wardrobe change pack
feels a little bit heavier today oh I'm
a little tender well we found a lot of
cool stuff but there was one waterfall
that we didn't find and so we were
poking around and we found this trail
here that we didn't check down so we're
gonna go maybe 10 15 minutes down this
trail and see if we can't find that
waterfall
look at this he's got a pretty decent
trail here look how gorgeous this is
look at that gorgeous swimming hole man
that is so clear I bet that's ten feet
deep it's so deceptive when it's clear
water like that
Hey look there it is we found the
waterfall that's awesome here let's go
down here look at this
[Music]
Wow we founded this is the falls
whoa look at that this is gorgeous
so call this tocome oh no nope nope nope
nope nope nope
man this is a gorgeous spot and looks
like a few people of camp right here on
top of the falls and have you strung a
hammock up here that would be pretty
pretty amazing
holy background glad we found this
they're just scary wiggle your toes we
going anything have you had fun I'm glad
you came along with me now you're ready
to go home and see mama
you did it that was so cool I'm so glad
we didn't give up we found that
waterfall you know we got to come back
here when it's hot in the middle of
summer this would be such an awesome
place to swim we've got a long hike back
to the car but this time we're not gonna
go up on the cliffs we're gonna go and
Ford the rivers whenever we need to feel
a lot more comfortable doing that and
getting my feet wet then putting Nathan
up on those rocks again well the river
has dropped a couple inches overnight so
hopefully that'll mean we have to do a
lot less bushwhacking and slogging
through flooded trails so I'm optimistic
our return trip might be a little bit
easier
looking sketchy
whoa
like a prayer
more washed out trail you got that doing
a great job
well this trail is terrible but the view
is amazing
[Music]
well look how much the waters gone down
[Music]
seeing a few brook trout here and there
I have to come back here go fly-fishing
[Music]
well guys I hope you enjoyed this video
as much as we enjoyed making this video
if you want to see more camping videos
check out our playlist I'll put a link
in the description we've done survival
camping in Scotland Alaska the Rocky
Mountains and we're gonna be doing a lot
more so don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every Saturday
morning